one of the things people have been
talking about a lot since you show the
game is the voice protagonist in the
game where'd you come to that decision
to use that we wanted to tell this big
epic story and you know and do that in a
way that let the player sort of relay
emotion and have these emotional moments
and there's we realized you know there's
only so you know if you play fallout 3
you know Liam Neeson is the voice of
your dad and there are some good
emotional beats there but there's only
so much you can do when you're just
clicking on a line of dialogue and
there's no spoken response and you can't
so the emotional depth that we got by
having the voice protagonist had just
would actually way more way more intense
than I even expected like the advantages
of it yeah some of that was logistical
you know can we write we didn't want to
hold back what we would usually do with
yeah you know all the choice we want so
you know they have spent years on it
each of them have recorded over 13,000
lines and also we found you know we
found two great voice actors for the
male and the female players yeah well
Todd could can you believe it we
actually have them here leave it yeah so
we'd like to welcome to the stage voice
actors brian te Delanie courtney taylor
and voice director kal kal el
Bogdanovich how'd I do not well so
welcome guys it's pretty exciting to
have you guys and and I guess Courtney
wasn't able to make it when yes yes
she's lost somewhere in the electronic
miasma yeah try and get her here okay so
how did you guys get started on the
project I remember I looked it up and uh
July 9 2013 was my first day of work and
I remember I knew this was going to be a
big deal but uh but I didn't know the
game title I only knew the code name
yeah so we show up and I do the first
line which happens to be war war never
changes and I I say a cow just can they
can you tell me what the name
the game is that he says well yeah you
know it's you know the line right the
line of course yeah I know I didn't so
when he told me and the scope of the
game and what they were doing and what
Todd and the team we're doing it kind of
blew me away even more so than when I
first found out I booked the job so
pretty cool cool what are some unique
characteristics of working on a project
this this massive compared to other
things you've worked on the number one
difference between this and then many
other games that I've worked on is the
amount of time and care that has gone
into the writing and then the recording
of this material I don't know how much
you guys know about this but in a lot of
other games Triple A games they'll wait
till like the last month or two to
record everything for the game and util
huge rush and sometimes you're doing
like a hundred lines an hour and it's
nuts to have had the artistic luxury of
being able to work on this with these
two unfortunately Courtney's not here
these two incredibly talented actors for
as long as we have almost three years
definitely three by the time it launches
is just it shows a an attention to
detail and a respect for the material
and for the audience that you just don't
see elsewhere it's really extraordinary
yeah and for you guys what's it been
like working with them awesome you know
it's a again that goes back to if we're
going to really do this the way we want
we need to logistically figure out how
we can record voice for four years and
so you know Cal came in early we did
some we also there's some performance
capture we do in the game so there's
that that part of it as well and we were
anxious you know about having a voice
because like it changes like how do I
feel about my character and we heard
Brian and Courtney it and we obviously
we we auditioned
a ton of he i don't know if you know how
many oh yeah it was oh yeah get out
really oh yeah are you were number one
and we'd have team voted so we would we
would put up various pictures of
different character faces and make
everyone in the team you don't know so
get everybody in team listen to them and
like okay because sometimes you get a
good a good voice but he doesn't feel
right to everybody and it was like a you
know Kourtney hey Kourtney Taylor this
was a late idea by the way everybody
like oh you should come it'll be it'll
be great but anyway finding them really
made it made all the difference and as
weird actually today's the first day
actually met face to face no and like
I've been listening to his voice as the
character and they both have really
owned the characters for years in it it
got better and better and better yeah
and we'll could speak to it too as
mostly writing you know you talk about
so there you know you can play the game
as a female protagonist rimmel
protagonist and you so everything so
either gender can do everything in the
game right so it was a it was really
cool for me to see the differences in
the lines in the end the things that
Brian brought and the things are
Courtney brought was sometimes
completely different like I would write
them a certain way or the designers
would write these things a certain way
and you would expect a certain
performance and then they would deliver
something way beyond what you even
expected and so that and that actually
happened very early and that you know it
spoke earlier earlier of trust it
establishes trust with you know when you
have this very emotional story and the
trust you have to have that these you
know these folks are going to knock it
out of the park it just the the
recording sessions almost became
conversational you know what I mean just
like let's go and let's do it you know
and the communication to be able to talk
to these guys and callebaut that's not
working can we try it this way yeah
world of difference well we're actually
running out of time here thanks
everybody for showing Brian I have one
request for you maybe you could give the
whole audience let's go pal
let's go pal